what's going on guys
what's going on man we're just doing
press living the dream hanging out i'm
sure everything's funny you're all
exhausted
yeah we're losing our minds a little bit
yeah we haven't been in this room all
day it's been a long one
i don't even know what what it looks
like outside it's probably dark i don't
know what the same way it was when we
woke up honestly anything could be
happening i couldn't tell you yeah
yeah this time of year i wouldn't i
wouldn't doubt it but uh okay so i
actually opened this up to my fans i was
like hey guys like do any of you have
questions you want to ask like tom
holland isn't there jacob adele and all
that kind of stuff so they absolutely
adore you all just so you know
they absolutely love you so the first
question they had um were any of you all
expecting
this level of hype for this movie
because i think the hype for this movie
actually exceeds avengers in-game
um i would tell you
i'll say
that
what as a fan myself yeah yeah i was
pretty hyped right right and so i don't
know what that means for the world but i
was like this is
tight
this is time spider-man is what i'm
going to say
i think we knew it was going to be big
but not this big for sure
yeah that's fair um okay the second
question is actually for zendaya
and jacob babylon oh
whoa
if each of you could steal one of
spider-man's powers
which one would it be
uh i kind of like that
you could like
can you run super fast or no well i
think because he's super strong
theoretically yes he could run super
fast i think you know what i like
sticking to walls i think that's pretty
cool
they're not running so not running yeah
now now that you say it it's like i
think it's thing in the walls is
probably cool yeah i was gonna say
spider sense but i feel like i already
have one like i feel like i know when
certain things are gonna i was gonna
pretend to do something but i didn't
want the world to be like tom holland
tries to hit sunday night
i don't like that but like i think with
different things i have like a certain
sense about certain things you know
whatever things are gonna whatever but
um
yeah maybe the strength thing is tight
because i can't even
versatile thing i can't even do a
push-up so it would be nice to be able
to lift the car
yeah or if you just do a push-up or just
do a push-up yeah
start there for sure
okay uh the final question i have here
um the last time i interviewed you tom
holland yes i asked you if you could
cross over with anybody who would it be
and you said wolverine
wow so the question it was like two
years ago man i don't expect you to
remember
so the question i would ask now is if
the two of you did fight
like you and hugh jackman right who wins
are we talking like logan wolverine are
we talking like x-men origins wolverine
oh
let's okay let's let's let's let's give
you this let's say old man logan yeah
seems too easy to beat up that old man
you gonna beat the old man origins he's
going through it
i watched that recently i watched it
recently
did we watch it
yeah
um
yeah we did watch it again yeah um
the movie is excellent i think wolverine
beats spider-man every single time
because there's no there's no amount of
battering that spider-man can do and
also spider-man doesn't kill people
and wolverine does so that is a huge
advantage he had yeah
could you could you cut off his head and
would that regrow
for wolverine
what
what's going on guys this is rob and i
answer the question of zendaya and tom
holland and jacob babylon even though i
look like a crazy guy who's basically
given up on himself uh there's a few
ways to kill wolverine permanently the
first way was introduced in excalibur
issue number 100 in 1996 and it's called
the xavier protocols basically they were
a series of protocols that professor x
of the x-men created on the off chance
that any one of the x-men went nuts and
tried to kill the world and so with
wolverine according to the xavier
protocols the only way to kill him is to
cut his head off from his body and then
keep his head and his body separated
this runs into issues like how do you do
that if he has like an adamantium spine
how do you cut a spine different things
like that in more recent years marvel's
introduce a couple different things that
can actually kill wolverine outside of
cutting his head off the first one is
using like a carbonadium sword which
would basically disrupt his healing
factor a more finite answer is to use
something called the muramasa blade and
the miramasa blade is actually a sword
that wolverine had created which was
designed to cut off his healing factor
and it's not just him if you stab
anybody with a mirror muscle blade
spider-man deadpool wolverine it doesn't
matter if they have a healing factor the
blade will deactivate their healing
factor and then they're just as easy to
kill as anybody else minus the
adamantium bonded to wolverine skeleton
but in more recent years what they also
did is they basically encased him in
adamantium and then left him there until
he ended up you know getting free and
coming back but to answer your question
that's basically the ways in which you
could kill wolverine anyway uh on to the
interview
because he has like super fast healing
right yeah oh i think the idea is but i
don't think it regrows i think
it just heals
how does that make sense what if like if
you were to slice his head like i don't
think he's like a reptile like like he i
don't think like if you so you say
picked it up and put it back on it would
heal or are you saying if you cut it off
you would grow a new one you wouldn't
grow a new one no so he would die he
would probably that's what i think right
so i feel like there's a way
sorry sorry he's so sorry getting into a
superhero
i don't think that peter parker would
kill wolverine right now right sure
especially hugh jackman
i need tap dancing lessons from you
jackman i'm about to play freda's day
i'm going to
help you
awesome well i appreciate you guys if i
had more time i'd answer that question
but uh i gotta bounce off here thank you
everybody